i just realized you have an action
figure uh on you
right that has to be very very strange
having a figure or am i wrong about this
no you're wrong about that it's really
fun to play with and uh actually i got
it from simu it was a present from him
that's great i can't imagine what it's
like to have an action figure i i mean
i'll never experience it
oh it's fun
did you have one
uh not yet but um when they start making
the bigger toys we can talk
so i am curious this is your first big
movie this is your first movie like this
is right so i'm curious what was the
experience of making the film compared
to maybe the way you thought it would be
going in i didn't have any
camera experience before so
i i didn't know what it would like and
the whole journey was just like
a master class to me
because i got to work with
so many legends you know
it's just like
like a dream come true
you know we have we have servant we have
tony long we have michelle yo
alcofina simu i mean all of them i just
learned so much from them
which of your friends and family were
the most excited that you got a marvel
movie i didn't know i was auditioning
for a marvel film
and
i sent myself tapes and when they flew
me to do the screen test with simu
that's when i found out i was
auditioning for shanxi
and
after five days of that screen test i
got a message from my lawyer
i didn't read through i just scrolled
down to the very bottom and i saw
welcome to the marvel universe
and yes
i you know i
i can keep big secret
i didn't tell my parents believe it or
not i didn't tell them
because i i i keep the secret you know
and
when
i have to fly to
shoot the film
i had to tell them and
they couldn't believe me
i said okay so it's a it's a film it's a
marvel film
and my mom was like no you're lying i
said no i'm not
they're really excited
oh i'm i can only imagine um i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of of a movie um what do you
think would surprise people to learn
about the making of shanghai
it's such an amazing story about family
and love and we poured a lot of heart
and hard work into making it
and
i mean
my my favorite
memory on set
was my first
fight scene with semu
and i did punch him in the face
and yes audience can see it in the film
yes
i was nervous because that was the very
first fight scene
and
simul encouraged me he said it's okay
it's okay just just go for it you can't
hurt me so i went for it i just got into
my character
i it was an accident but to be honest it
was an accident
[Laughter]
it felt good
[Laughter]
okay well i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say i hope this is a huge hit and please
enjoy the action figure that's awesome
thank you so much nice talking to you
have a great day thank you thank you you
too